Slovakia is a neighboring country very
much understands the needs of Ukraine
Slovakia is a neighboring country to
Ukraine very much supports Ukraine in
all possible ways and we appreciate very
much the effort of all the developed
Democratic countries to Ukraine either
Financial or humanitarian or military
health this is all needed for Ukraine
but we have to think also helping them
with export of their grain we know that
Ukraine is a great exporter of grain we
started in a spring of this year All
European Union opening the solidarity
lanes for exporting this grain this was
very important and it brought a lot of
help to Ukraine of course freeing the
port of Odessa was a great help as well
but we see that there is not enough
stability for this export that's why we
have to continue with the solidarity
Lanes we have to strengthen them we have
to emphasize its need and we have to
stay United in helping Ukraine in
exporting the grain because it's income
for them and it's also a great help to
the other countries outside of Europe to
prevent any food crisis or famine please
let's stay United in helping crane also
through the solidarity Lanes it is
important